This is par for the Brooklyn public library are our stories
project and here our
local library lady Archer.
With a for her in a way
where well I was born in London but my father was
killed in the second world war. You know how old I am and I was brought to Canada I was raised
in Canada. Not a typical childhood spent some time in foster
homes which I think perhaps
made me more ready to live communally in a way and then came to scald country to go to the
university and then move to New York for graduate school. And then we moved to
Brooklyn to live in a commune.
I'm going to go on forever. The main This was the very beginning of the women's
movement and we call it the Women's Liberation Movement the word
feminist has not yet been mentioned and mainly unlike
today and it's really hard to imagine men took no role in
childcare whatsoever in those days
even kind in Latin men so the main force in the commune
with to get men to get to share
childcare so that other women could help you raise your children
and men would do their share so originally to families.
My my my ex-husband and I and a friend and her husband. We
had to find we couldn't afford to do it we had to find another family which we did.
So there were six adults and five children who bought a house on sixth
Street to family house originally built as a two family house that was extra wide
and long it was quite big for a Brooklyn house.
People now are amazed that it cost seventy five thousand dollars but that was a lot of
money you could only get Brooklyn was redlined.
You could only get a forty thousand dollars mortgage. So we had to come up with twenty thousand dollars
and would borrow some money and we were. It was very very hard
financially but we moved in one nine hundred seventy two Christmas one nine hundred seventy two
and we lived together for thirteen
years as a calling you.
Mean I could just keep talking or you could ask me some question. Well the I Have I want to say
right from the beginning everybody always says oh you know sex there was it was just agreed right from
the beginning the no sex no really we didn't read Marx
together we were all very
leftist and we all pretty much agree we were going to get no more we
were working in civil rights and women's health issues. And we
just agreed and we were just sort of new we sort of agreed about the raising of
children you know not too strict but
not not to. You
know we we had very much high standards for the children they participated they set the table
and everything the biggest challenge in the Conran were was
setting up a schedule and the schedule involved
childcare making dinner doing the shopping and doing
other household tasks and getting that together. Everybody had to
be somewhat flexible in their work.
It's not always possible.
But two of us were teachers at the college level so we could usually have one day off.
And you really you ended up cooking only one day a week so we ate incredibly
well because somebody cooked a big meal one day a week for twelve people.
We were very involved and we had a house a big house with about. Let's
see twelve. Six bedrooms in the two unit. So
every in a way and funny when people have more privacy when we live communally than they did
when we then broke up the commune because we shared living space that's all we
shared and then every couple had two rooms. Bedroom study
two bedrooms depending on their work hours and the children
shared
about five children shared three
rooms and probably the
biggest issue was decorating the place.
Because that was so unnecessary you know we we were never disagreed about we
had to pay the mortgage we pay the taxes we fix the roof when it leaked we had a very we have a lot
of maintenance issues but my ex-husband was very handy so he did a lot of
that to this day I am close
to the two other families. I have a huge extended family
and they all live in Brooklyn and I don't have any grandchildren of my own but I'm sort of like a
grandmother great aunt to about seven my
community or grandchildren and a sort of an
answer to for how many for five children
so it's been it's been fabulous in that way.
When asked if I could keep going on but I feel like I'm so.
Well one of the women two of us were actually English.
So I met after college and went to live in England for a year with
my grandmother and then I met a woman who it was very we
were sort of a modern early women stuff that's what we were involved with that was the major We
were involved in women's health issues in New York City especially because we saw that women's health
was an
issue that really
did concern all women. So even if we were mostly
middle class women which was the criticism that was often leveled that the women's
movement at that time health was something that everybody needed help on
getting access to child care to birth control and to
abortion although now we have to call that choice but
we were very active around. And outlaw the New York state
abortion laws which were you couldn't get a legal abortion in New York State in the in
the sixty's we all had children. That was the other thing we were all
struggling for child care. We couldn't.
Firstly there were no daycare centers to speak
of and we couldn't and didn't want to afford a nanny only very very
very rich people had
nannies and so we were constantly juggling we had
childcare groups babysitting groups are you gay people
like token his and then you know they all just for hours you wore them for hours and that's how
I raised my children my son for the first couple of years because my ex-husband was
working full time you know there were very few options and a big prejudice against
women who were it was very very
different and so that was the main thing that we had to work go
to how we could raise our children with more
help from the man and with help from each other we also thought and I was a
young mother I'd never had any. I'd never been raised with other
children. I was happy to have other
people help me raise my children. I think more the attitude
today is I'm the one taking care of my children we were I was thrilled to
have other people raise my children with me and see how they did it and what they did.
And I think the only issue really in the end was space because
one marriage broke out and. That woman got together with another guy
who had two children and we have room for. I would have
a children for
that so they eventually that family moved out moved up the street
we made we still remain very close to them and did a lot of things together and then two
families lived together
communally for the next seven years and even we broke up the commune and they moved up stairs.
We put it back to the two family house at. Always was we had
meetings we had we really had no political disagreements there were some times
when we felt one child or another needed a little discipline and
that was an issue.
Are real issues I never criticize what people did
their children and what I thought was really serious but it never was that serious.
So I think that we were just.
We we all
agreed. To respect each other's privacy as much as
possible you know for the Sunday morning and people reading the times you didn't talk to them.
But
or you went up to your room to read the Times you know. We
paid the financial issues were really amazingly not an issue. We
each paid. The same amount every month. Even though there was slight
variation in family size to adult. You know and. It was so much less.
I mean I think was five hundred dollars a month. We paid which
covered all the house expenses the mortgage along with the taxes the insurance all
the food and of course all the
childcare. Even for then that was a little amount of money to spend
so even though we were hard
pressed and there were constant meet Nathan's issues we somehow managed to never
have major issues of money which was pretty amazing really and the
only issues we had really as I said were the aesthetic issues of what to put
on the walls.
And occasionally a bit of difference
around. Well again how much you should spend for a rug for the living room
so that sort of thing is to sort of cheat a little bit put in some of my own
money so and it was just and but it was also a very different time
because we were very
involved in the block. So we helped organize block parties we were
very organized in the P.T.A.. And we're very organized in sort of
we had baseball games in Prospect Park it was a different
time you know we saw organizing we saw block
parties as ways of sort of community outreach a lot of lovely
young people on my block today but when they give a block party.
It's just
for the ten people who decide to give it you know they don't put flyers in the
apartment buildings and there's a bit of a owner renter divide now has
happened on the block which really didn't exist in the past. I mean they. I don't think
it did exist because none of us
were even those of us who lived in houses were not obviously wealthy.
Whereas now today the people who live by the new houses and they're really wealthy.
So it was a it was a different time and I think then we didn't think communal living
was so unusual that it made sense to share
childcare.
Well. You know now that I think about it not as many I've heard of I knew of one other family.
And I knew about two
more and I knew of somewhere there were no children.
You know it was just for adults more like what you have today with flat sharing.
But this was really done with a.
I suppose with a political agenda that it was preferable
to living alone and there was some notion of
monogamy was not didn't. Wasn't really for the human condition that
people should be able to have this would allow people. I mean a cynical
view there's a good deal of the Commune which would be that since it was Jewish Jews
and Christians in it that the commune allowed some people to celebrate
Christmas and some guys to have affairs if I do have to put it
that way because that did happen and to put it we did put a strain and eventually
my relationship with my husband broke
up. Sort of a nickel Blee in the end
because it didn't leave us as desperate because there
I was living in this
house which in fact a tiny bit of money from
my grandmother had allowed me
to I sort of own the house more than my ex-husband so that made it but he'd done.
Alison's of dollars of work on it but he you know just said I have no claim to the
house and moved two blocks away and we get along just fine and so it was good but
it did mean
that I wasn't sort
of desperate. When my husband ex-husband and I broke up
and sometimes I see the young women today who've stopped working to raise their children.
I do understand that but I also think
while a lot of marriages end up in divorce and what you're going to do if you have no
foot in the.
In the workplace. Apart from your identity issues and earning your own money.
It really I
think. We just had a buffer for the kids and I think they would all agree.
I mean they would
criticize sometimes and you hear them talk about how we were poor so we had
margarine not butter in the days when we thought margarine and really nice
kids go on about that again. Wow Get a life on
the whole
really we were pretty much all committed to making it work and I think that's
what made it work. We saw in it but it paid off such big
time you know you'd leave for work in the morning. Your good friend Alice or
Rachel with you holding your kid and waving to you from the window and maybe the kid would cry for
one minute but them are off off and running playing there was like a a daycare
center in the
house and basement that was great to play
in I think all the kids would say was a great way to grow
up but I think it's hard to live as young women because I've been fond of
my grandchildren that I meet in playgrounds. Why. You do this and one
of the answers is financial that the pricing housing prices are so
great that in order to buy a
house you need to have a rental unit that you can charge some
outlandish amount of money
for in order to pay the mortgage but I also think it's more of a it's
also a psychological thing
or there's a lot of pressure on young parents
today and especially young women to be like perfect mothers.
I think we all knew we were perfect
mothers and that we could balance that by someone else.
You know having another person there
to take over a meal was also if your kid was sick.
You didn't always have to miss
work. If you weren't on there's a famous story about a little boy who came down
the one who was a bit. Sometimes difficult.
My English friend was very
strict you know if you wanted something at the dinner table you said Rachel
could you please pass the butter you didn't reach and just grab it or you didn't take
the muffin E. half of it and put it back that manners but
I said. So this little boy came down one day
and he was just dressed like she was were tired and is here you know
whatever and instead of saying to his
mother Mom you know I need your money to help me he said to her she was rushing up to
her who was on today by which she meant to
which adult should I go to have the time i Shares and I thought that was really
great my friend feels guilty but that is another great we recognize that one of us was
there and our job was if you were on a tremendous amount of work you got up
early you made breakfast
for eleven people September first but they had great
practice you know every day something different you got the kids to
school unless one of the working adults said OK I'll drop them off at three
twenty
one you pick them up for lunch.
And brought them home and took them back to pick them up after school you made dinner was a lot
of work.
You didn't do the clean up. Maybe you did do the clean up it was a huge day of
work but then you were off the rest of the week even though you were often around and
don't want
to I was often around because I was a teacher I was upstairs grading papers. So there was
often somebody else at home to do backa it wasn't like one person. The kid only saw
the parent one day a week it wasn't like that at all and we all put our own kids
to bed pretty
much unless we were late but we were there for them a huge amount.
But we also you know the older kids read to the younger
kids Lego was a huge thing that was like a sea of Lego see a Lego.
And it was the old Lego didn't it didn't come in sets so you built your own
you know you
didn't. It wasn't like oh this is Star Trek build your starship it was
just build whatever you want to build it was very imaginative and that we had huge color and we had
shoes art supplies and then it was a fabulous way to grow
up and that was his basement which in those days didn't get wet we weren't getting the storms
we get now and they had a whole other world down there. That's what many of them would remember
the total privacy of the basement. Because they were left.
I mean you left the door open. You could hear that they were OK but in the basement they
were in their own
world and that was really. And then you know we had great
celebrations Christmas especially Thanksgiving very festive times I mean it's much nicer to come
down to a Christmas tree with.
Sixty presents under it even though it only it only adds up to four or five presents a person
but because there were so many people it was very festive I think that's been an adjustment for some of them
they're living with their spouse and one child and there's only two to presents passing
over so anyway it broke up in one nine hundred eighty five
because two of the children were off to college and.
One of the couples really
wanted not so much more privacy but they wanted to be able to have more friends stay
over and so they had to separate you know as I said just putting the house it
didn't cost much money just put the house back into the two family house it had always
been they just report the kitchen and it was the kitchen we hadn't
totally taken out the pipes or anything you know.
So it was and then we continued to
live still quite cooperatively in terms of all
sorts of things in sharing like tricity and heat and wire and everything like that I mean
I always said you couldn't live like this if you weren't willing to be generous about all
of the bills and everything had
to agree that whatever. Anyway so you can ask me something I'll
be happy.
Yes.
Well I went to when I was eighteen graduating high school in Toronto my brother was
going back to London to go to drama school and my
mother was clear was saying that she was going to go back to London although she did
stay in Toronto until she retired but
I applied to university I went
to I went to Raghav College Cambridge Massachusetts and
I'm on a total scholarship I have to say and then
I sort of had to decide was I going to go back to Toronto but I
wasn't Canadian I hadn't become a
Canadian so I applied to I got into Columbia graduate school I
just came to New York City English with an English major
and those were the days of
I I feel very badly for young people today I got my
whole education
to. Excellent school for Bourke virtually a thousand dollars.
I got total scholarships. Which when I was an
undergraduate was totally because my mother was a widow. And it wasn't working that time she was very sick.
But in high in college it was just you did well enough you got some fellowship.
They paid for everything and gave you
money but some believe. So I
had no college debt which is something I think real privilege.
A privilege and I you
know we made that the goal I mean actually living this way in
the community and then even sharing a house we know our
co-op was a very thrifty way to live and we sort
of decided that one of our goals would be to help our
kids go to college debt free because it was a
bird with a bird's eye but I also
think because I didn't grow up
with a perfect mother because she was always working
and we were in foster homes my brother and me and we were boarding school. I didn't
have incredible standards of what kind of mother I should be
at some point I decided to learn to make chocolate chip cookies because although I hate chocolate
because I thought this was the American mom thing we had to make chocolate chip cookies
and I apparently make very good ones which I have never ever had
one never tasted one of my chocolate chip cookies but so you know and we.
I just didn't have those high standards. And a
very
occasionally when my son or my daughter would guilt trip me a little bit I would
think you have both parents. You have all sorts of other people involved you
know get a life. You're very lucky. So I wasn't quite
like I mean friends or my ex-husband and I broke up and it was quite in the couple and
he lived not very far away and we had a rule of thumb if one of us can go to
the soccer game.
That's fine you don't need both parents at the soccer game the other person could be having spending some time
alone and they think. That we didn't spoil the kids in that
way but we chipped them
lots of attention to say the least it's funny I have had a lot of thoughts about
my child and it wasn't that typical for a middle class person who ended up
middle class.
Because my brother died recently and I was going through a lot of
it but I just I think that in the end.
I had a certain toughness to the world which was good because when I got to Harvard
and Radcliff I really needed it because I was faced with a real privilege.
I had never quite encountered that though not as much privileges.
There were this many rich rich rich people in those days and people well.
People didn't go in the kind of occasions they go on you know and they didn't fly all over the world
to ski and everything so even at Harvard I didn't know many there were very wealthy
people but I didn't you didn't have to know
them you know I didn't dominate in any way.
So I just think that the and it was an exciting time the sixty's you know
very whenever people you know there's a lot of badmouthing of the sixty's
but everybody I know went through it with the ended up in some sort of
vaguely useful job. You know I don't know anybody who went into banking
we're going to stock. You know may keep being hedge fund is their role in social services
teaching justice was a good time.
Not to say this isn't a good time to I don't like it but I just think it was a very different time there was a
feeling of well there was the war to fight against. And as it turns out we
were right about the war it was
a disastrous war big
mistake terrible
policies in fact we were more right than we
knew anyway but Aracely
some think of that.
Well
it's gotten much wealthier. I mean when we moved in people
almost it especially our block the
park blocks were always off. But still all the but all the houses were
rooming house and they were
all. And you wouldn't know it from looking at the brownstone facade some of them
still are actually but we have one two
three four five seven five small apartment blocks
so we always had
a mix of renters and people who lived there when we first moved
into the block the neighborhood was totally Irish Irish
Catholic. And when we first moved into the block.
There was some anti semitism. And I remember an incident
where I was lighting the menorah I was in Jewish but I was the one who Lipmann or with
the
kids and I heard someone scream Jews on sixty and
I pushed the kids down because I half expected a rock through the
window. And the big Catholic Church across the street St
Saviour's which has much improved but at no time it offered nothing in the way of services to
the communal childcare no summer camp. And they were some somewhat annoyed
at the hippies who were moving and you know living in a commune and we weren't the there were other people on
the street.
You know who occasionally sat on their students smoking marijuana cigarette they
were. They were aware of the change but once it turned
out that we took care in once they saw that we were taking care of the place.
But then it just became this and the school three twenty one was much
more in a strange way. More racially
nicks and more economically mixed because it was a Title one school because with a title
one school. There were something like three to
four G.. Got of free time every
day so they had
to provide when you do it the kids in that free time so my son had
music. All sorts of things that my daughter when she went to the school ten
years later never had because it wasn't for school anymore. So the P.T.A. had to fund
that wasn't provided so in some ways she got I thought a better
education in that way you can get a better education in terms of
the school has become so much more enlightened
about pedagogy. But the neighborhood has become
just much more well the more
people I would say less community
spirit more. I don't want to complain about the children of Park
Slope but I think a lot of children are being raised to be not
as aware of others as our children were raised you
know don't bump into people you know apologized to people don't acknowledge
in restaurants just that sort of thing. I think that it is just a
different time.
There are block parties and there are
social involved but I don't think people are as involved because
I
think even though we all worked and many women
were use of kids played on the street you could still let kids play on the street you know you
could even let your kids.
Well I don't know when we first let them go to Prospect Park. They could walk to school on their own that was no big
deal to see a group of kids walking to school and now you almost never do you see that
when you drive to the neighborhood.
I remember once that last spring I was driving from a doctor you mean that was a beautiful early
spring day and I drove
through you know Bed Stuy in Brownsville and I saw these children playing on the
street hopscotch and closer I got to park slope in Park Slope there wasn't
a kid on the
street because they were all in fencing. And after school you know
the kids' time is much more programmed.
I mean I only my son took one after school activity and my daughter
took he came home we played on the street play stickball play. Then
my daughter took I think one class just I think it's
about children women working
more but also the ethos that children have to be
totally stimulated and given all these opportunities which I think
is contributing to the whole we talk a lot about the financial economic
equity divide but I think there's a huge divide between children the enrichment
of getting poor parents just can't
do I think it's very poor kids and.
You know schools here the teachers were in grade one kindergarten would say there's no
problem teaching reading they don't know how to read.
Whereas I think in four schools that's a real
issue with the different time and I
think. The neighborhood was
once people used to tell me how their parents sold their house on Tenth Street to move to
Staten
Island. Now they wish they had a back. Because
it was their houses were run down and.
What I found and I read about the neighborhood I think genes are really that
dangerous the Underground is a wreck.
You know things have improved in New York and it was nowhere near as green.
I mean the park was kind
of still sick. Trying to survive what Robert
Moses had done you know putting cemented everywhere and it was in very
very bad shape because they park alliance with me.
So with any other.
You know and I think
that just to say that I wish more people could think of doing it.
I think their lives would be a lot easier although there are always the pressures
of finding the right group of
people because actually once you think about it there's everybody could be annoying
to you but I think that's what we really rose above that level of
pettiness because we saw the greater
good world pretty much friends
today one of us is all right so
I'm hoping to write it up I haven't written up so then I'll let you have
that right now thank you very much was
great great and I have to go home and start looking through files.